you
imagine it's a beautiful day in April of
2017 three children in different parts
of the world are going about their daily
lives as they do every day and as their
parents have done for countless
generations meet hero in Japan hero
wants to be a successful banker one day
just like his father but right now he's
more interested in spaceships and
planets Abbasi lives in Kenya with his
parents and grandparents one day he
wants to travel the world in his own
little sailboat Akash lives in India
with his big happy family
when Akash grows up he wants to be the
world's greatest chef and so life goes
on
Hiro becomes an astronaut much to his
father's surprise Abbasi travels the
world in his sailboat and Akash opened
up his own restaurant in his hometown
they grow old and pass on having lived
fulfilled lives their children follow
and their children's children until one
day in April of 2100 Eiko and his family
are crammed with thousands of other
people at Haneda Airport hoping it's not
too late sadly that people of Tokyo
never had a chance the once proud City
is reduced to rubble by tsunami the
likes of which has never been seen Inasa
lies in the dark of his quiet home and
he knows his time has come it hasn't
rained in months all the crops and
livestock have died and the well dried
up long ago the people of Kenya suffer
the slow death of starvation and
dehydration Ani draws ragged breaths in
his hospital bed his body ravaged by
disease he's the last living member of
his family the population of India has
fallen drastically these are a few
hypothetical scenarios from various
parts of the globe while they may seem
unrelated they all share a common
catalyst climate change as 2017 begins
and the United States presidency changes
hands it has become increasingly
apparent that the new regime is full of
climate change deniers and fossil fuel
advocates it is more important than ever
to spread real information regarding
climate change and the catastrophic
effect it can produce within the next
100 years let's start with a common
misconception when some people hear the
term global warming they'll point to an
instance of colder than normal weather
like the Sahara Desert recently and say
that's ridiculous it's snowing here this
objection stems from a misunderstanding
of how weather differs from climate
weather refers to local changes over
short periods of time such as minutes
hours days or weeks typical examples of
weather include rain clouds snow wind
and thunderstorms climate refers to
longer term
bridges and maybe regional or global in
scale and can be thought of as weather
average over an extended period of time
typically years or decades an easy way
to remember the distinction is weather
is what you get
climate is what you expect now that we
have a good understanding of how climate
and weather differ let's look at the
scientific consensus over 97% of
actively publishing climate scientists
agree that climate warming trends over
the past 100 years are extremely likely
to have been caused largely by human
activity that number goes up to over 99%
if you include climate scientists who
have not recently published scholarly
articles most of the leading scientific
organizations around the world have
issued public statements endorsing this
position there are too many to list in
this video so I've put a link in the
description of organizations and their
statements climate change deniers tend
to latch on to studies that disprove the
trend but you'll always notice that the
studies are either not peer-reviewed
come from a known anti science publisher
or come from a scientist in a completely
unrelated field with an agenda of their
own so where does this problem come from
the largest contributing factor to
climate change is the burning of fossil
fuels oil coal and natural gas all
release carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere when burned carbon dioxide is
considered a greenhouse gas which simply
means it sticks around in the upper
atmosphere and traps heat the more
carbon dioxide is released the more the
atmosphere heats up this temperature
increase then causes other problems such
as melting glaciers and polar ice as
Arctic ice melts it releases co2 and
methane a more potent greenhouse gas
compounding the problem by making the
atmosphere even warmer thus melting more
ice it's a vicious cycle ok but where do
we stand right now what's the damage as
of the end of 2016
carbon dioxide levels are up by nearly
four hundred and five parts per million
the highest in 650,000 years global
temperature is up by one point seven
degrees since 1880 and nine of the last
ten hottest years on record happened
since 2000 the tenth being 1998 Arctic
ice is shrinking at a rate of thirteen
point three percent per decade and land
ice is disappearing at a rate of 281
Giga tons per year Greenland ice loss
doubled between 1996 and 2005 and
finally the global sea level has risen
seven inches in the last 100 years
you're probably thinking well that
doesn't sound too bad let's look at the
consequences by category
first the melting of polar ice of course
we've all heard that global warming
affects the poor polar bears but it's
true and it's severe at the current rate
of melting which is likely to increase
the Arctic is projected to see its first
ice-free summer by 2050 imagine that all
of the ice gone and yes that likely
means extinction for the polar bears
within a hundred years and it's not just
polar bears some species of ice
dependent seals will die off if they
can't adapt including harp ringed ribbon
and bearded seals then there are the
ivory gulls and ox ivory gulls have
already suffered a 90% population
reduction in Canada over the past 20
years
then there's the walrus the arctic fox
small plant eaters like ground squirrels
hares lemmings and voles large plant
eaters like moose caribou reindeer and
musk ox and meat-eaters like weasels
Wolverines wolves foxes bears and birds
of prey the melting ice is likely to
cause a domino effect knocking out
species that other species depend upon
for food
melting ice brings us to our next
category rising sea level over the past
100 years the global sea level has risen
approximately seven inches the more
alarming fact is that the rate of rise
in the last decade is nearly double the
rate of the entire last century at this
rate rising sea level puts coastal
cities and islands at great risk as sea
water reaches further inland it can
cause destructive erosion flooding of
wetlands contamination of aquifers and
agricultural soils and lost habitat for
fish birds and plants most projections
show the sea level will rise between 0.8
and 2 meters by 2100 which would be
catastrophic for many low-lying islands
and much of the eastern coast of the
United States more dire predictions
based upon the complete melting of the
Greenland ice sheet project a rise of up
to 7 metres that's enough to submerge
London the third category is the one
with which most people are familiar
global temperature rise as co2
accumulates in our atmosphere the
temperature creeps steadily upward the
annual increase is measured at roughly
1.7 degrees Fahrenheit this increase in
temperature could cause the most drastic
immediate effects of all three
categories the list is long and
distressing so here we go global warming
will cause droughts and heat waves which
are already responsible for killing more
people per year than floods hurricanes
lightning and tornadoes combined it will
aggravate the spread of disease warmer
weather allows disease bears
be active longer and further abroad
warmer ocean temperatures will allow
pathogens to flourish as we've already
seen with the widespread coral bleaching
of the Great Barrier Reef this coral
houses 25% of all marine diversity and
the reef has already declined by 50% in
the last 30 years when the coral goes
we'll lose hundreds of thousands of
species dependent upon it for shelter
which will collapse much of the marine
food chain back on land fishing will
suffer droughts will destroy crops and
livestock and create a water scarcity
pushing farmers and people in rural
areas into the city this will cause
overcrowding and help spark civil wars
that kill hundreds of thousands like it
did in Syria GDP is expected to plummet
by 23 percent by 2100 caused by property
damage from flooding droughts wildfires
storms loss of productivity loss of
tourism and illness you can see how
quickly the situation can snowball
wildly out of control it seems very dire
but what can we do is it too late to
stop the changes we've put in motion
it's hard to say for sure
but the effect humans have had on this
earth is severe and the changes have
indeed been set in motion even if we
stopped emitting greenhouse gases today
global warming would continue for at
least several more decades since carbon
dioxide can linger in the atmosphere for
up to centuries some experts believe
we're approaching a tipping point a
point at which abrupt perhaps
irreversible changes would tip our
climate into a new state however it may
not be too late to limit some of the
worst effects of climate change two
important steps are required one
mitigation the reduction of greenhouse
gas emissions into the atmosphere and
two adaptation learning to cope with and
adapt to the climate changes that have
already been set in motion recycling and
driving fuel efficient cars are
important steps in the right direction
but not sufficient on their own it will
take a globally coordinated response
such as clean energy agreements between
nations as well as local efforts on the
city and regional level such as
sustainable city planning public
transportation upgrades and energy
efficiency improvements so yes
climate change is the biggest threat to
existence as we know it and is deeply
troubling that the United States
government seeks to normalize ignorant
of good science so if you're concerned
for the future of the planet and
generations to come do your part help
spread this information because the
earth truly is worth saving
if you enjoyed this video please leave a
like or a comment and subscribe to keep
up with the latest content thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you
[Music]